[Music]
well free speech has been ebbing away at
college campuses of course for many
years now colleges seem increasingly
able to take a joke literally constant
Kissin as a comedian he's the host of
the YouTube show trigonometry he was
recently invited to perform at a college
in London but the group that invited him
asked that he sign a contract promising
not to engage in any way in quote racism
sexism classism ageism ableism
homophobia biphobia transphobia
xenophobia Islamophobia anti religion or
anti atheist that's a long list what was
he supposed to joke about
well we've asked him to come on tonight
to tell us mr. custom thank you very
much for coming did you make up that
list is this a comedy bet no it's not
it's been very good for my comedy but
actually if you go further into the
contract they also demand that that all
jokes must be respectful and kind which
I think really takes the biscuit as you
know I was born in the Soviet Union
and this really did get in this contract
made me feel right at home it's a little
handed I would say but what is it I mean
you're a working comedian that's why I'm
so grateful you're on what is your life
like now well it is getting very
sensitive and I think this is obviously
an outlier no one would suggest that
every University and colleges like this
but I think the reason that I made the
stand on this issue is I don't want it
to get worse I don't want this to
continue so it's so striking that this
is being applied to comedians these
standards they're being applied to all
of us we're all terrified all of us live
in fear and freedom really is
evaporating but comedians used to be the
one group that by definition was allowed
to be transgressive because that's the
whole point of comedy saying the thing
everywhere else is afraid to say is it
ominous do you think that comedians
aren't even allowed to practice I think
so I think so we're the canary in the
coal mine and I think this is why it's
gone viral I think it's nothing to do
with comedy this story actually the
reason that people all around the world
that are tuning in and and watching the
video we recorded of of this is because
it's not about comedy it's about
ordinary people up and down the country
and here in Britain and in
America feeling like they can't say what
they think I've had so many messages
from people messaging me all kinds of
people sometimes women going you know
what I don't agree with radical feminism
and if I say that in the workplace
tomorrow I won't have a job anymore so
what it's coming to is the fact that
everybody feels like we're we're all
kind of under arrest we're all all
everything we say can and will be used
against us in the court of public
opinion and they're coming for the
comedian's first because we're we're the
ones that as you say are allowed to
transgress but everybody else feels it
and that's why the story's got the
resonance though it has it's not this is
not sustainable this moment take Kevin
Carson thank you very much god bless you
for what you're doing I appreciate it
thanks for having me Tucker I think
freedom of speech is absolute and there
should be no restrictions on it
whatsoever no hate speech laws I want to
scrap all of those no public order
legislation that targets speech no libel
laws I think there should be no
restrictions whatsoever and the best
response to speech that is wrong or
dangerous or racist or horrible is
always more speech never censorship
never laws never putting someone in
prison so I'm a free speech absolutist
because I think freedom of speech should
be completely unfettered and loose on
the world so you think for instance it
should be acceptable for somebody for
instance in a mom to go be able to go up
on a street corner post and on a pallet
and say homosexual should be murdered
for instance further yes yes and I
actually have defended Imams who have
horrible views about homosexuality or
women or whatever else it might be which
a lot of free speech activists that they
actually run out of steam when it comes
to defending extreme Islamists I
definitely do I think yeah right and
they suddenly think I can't do that but
I think obviously there is such a thing
as incitement to violence and that's not
a free speech issue for the base from
the point of view that if you are
inciting violence you are conspiring in
the commission of a crime so that goes
beyond freedom of speech and then you
are part of a criminal conspiracy of
some description but I think even when
it comes to incitement to violence we
have to be
really specific because that has become
a very misused term I was really struck
that the Metropolitan Police this week
or last week they were talking about
drill videos on YouTube drill is the
latest form of grime music lots of young
black kids listen to it in London and
elsewhere very violent music kind of
praises gangs and stabbing attacks and
guns and so on so it's and people are
very scared it's like the new gangster
raps yeah but in Britain instead of the
US and the police made this incredibly
interesting statement where they said
we're taking down hundreds of these
videos because we think they're
dangerous so I think that was an act of
police censorship and they said even if
there is no obvious act of violence that
has been incited bit by these videos we
can still say that these videos incite
violence I thought that was really
interesting because in Simon 2 violence
now means pretty much anything you want
it to mean it basically just means that
you really hate this form of speech
whether it's a drill video whether it's
Germaine Greer going to Cardiff
University and arguing the trans people
on real women that's also described as
incitement to violence pretty much any
form of speech can now be described as
incitement to violence so even there I
think we have to be very specific and I
would like to see evidence that the
speech in question directly contributed
to an act of violence before I would be
willing to sanction any form of
punishment for that speech but what's
interesting about that is that that has
all that argument has always been with
us if you think about the Jaime Bolger
killings I mean 20 odd years ago that
was blamed on computer video games if
you think about the Shu school students
in Boulder Colorado they blamed it on
Marilyn Manson yeah do you think you can
ever attribute you know an act of
violence to a particular type of thought
or oh yeah I think you can I think you
know the guy at Mark David Chapman who
shot General John Lennon was inspired to
do side by JD Salinger's Catcher in the
Rye he really genuinely thought that
Catcher in the Rye was giving him a
message to kill John Lennon so you could
argue that Catcher in the Rye caused the
death of John Lennon or Charles Manson
and his crazy family
inspired to kill all those people in Los
Angeles by the White Album I mean they
really genuinely believed it deep in
their heart that the White Album by the
Beatles contained all these messages
about race Wars and the piggies in the
capitalist society who needed to be
slaughtered and so on they really
believed that and of course you know
countless numbers of people have killed
because they read something in the Bible
or they believed something in the Koran
so it's unquestionable that ideas can
encourage people to commit violent acts
it's unquestionable that some people
will look at a piece of art or read a
book or hear a song and think to
themselves this work of art is telling
me to do something really bad but if you
were to organize society on the basis
that that might happen then you are
basically creating a lunatic asylum in
which all of us are punished on the
basis that one or two crazy people might
do something stupid after reading
Catcher in the Rye or listening to the
White Album and that would be a deeply
unpleasant society because there's no
end of cultural products or artistic
things that could be said to inspire
violence or hatefulness in one form or
another so I but my issue with media
affects theory which is this idea that
video nasties cause mass killings or
video games make the James Bulger murder
happen or in the modern version because
the left that effects Theory used to be
very prominent on the right among kind
of old Christian women and Mary
Whitehouse types and very conservative
stiff people now it's kind of shifted to
the left and it's very much more from
the left now that argues about media
effects theory and will say that lads
mags if they're in shop on shop shelves
will cause men to become rapacious and
anti women or violence against women in
films will cause men to commit violence
against women in real life so the left
has utterly embraced the media effects
Theory my problem with the media effects
theory is that it presents all people as
almost like animals who just look at
something and then think I must act on
that and that is a very demeaning view
of the vast majority of human beings who
actually are perfect
capable of thinking for themselves and
perfectly capable of making a decision
about what they should do with their
lives so I would be very wary of any
justification of censorship that was
made on the basis that we basically are
monkey-see monkey-do and that we see
something or hear something and then
immediately feel that we have to commit
a violent act on the back of it
[Music]
my model is nonviolent direct action
inspired by people like Martin Luther
King about so Mohandas Gandhi and others
I think their methods of peaceful direct
action and where appropriate some of
this obedience against unjust laws is
the model by which all successful
movements for social change have won
through but I'm curious about there will
be other there will have been other
people who have been watching Martin
Martin Luther King marching in and
seeing those movements who would not
have had the courage or whatever it is
that's driven you to risk your life and
limb essentially for what you believe in
what do you think it was that made you
prepared to do that to be willing to
risk your life essentially for that we
all right I mean my school friends also
sort the same images but didn't act I
guess I've just got quite a strong sense
of right and wrong perhaps an
overdeveloped conscience I don't like to
see other people suffering you know I
love freedom equality justice I love
other people I put myself in their shoes
if it was me who was being persecuted or
unjustly treated I would want someone to
help me so when I see others suffering I
think well if I want others to help me
in that situation then surely I have
some responsibility to do something to
try and help them and were you always
like that were you like that as a kid if
you saw something something justice
happening as a ten-year-old would you
try to step in or defend people who can
yeah yeah and I don't know exactly where
came from I suppose it's partly from my
very strict quite fundamentalist
Christian upbringing my parents
instilled me a very strong sense of you
know follow your own conscience don't
just go along with the mob think for
yourself stand up for what is right even
if it's unpopular
and you know from a religious point of
view be a good Samaritan
you know don't walk by the other side of
the street when someone is is suffering
so I guess that that was part of the
fact that impelled me to take up these
human rights causes III do not believe
that I have stopped changing my mind
about things and so I think is um you
know the ability to hear other opinions
and could mean that I might change my
mind and or improve the way I argue or
just get a new perspective on the world
so I'm from an entirely personal point
of view I think it's a peculiar idea to
have in your head that you know you at
any age say this is what I think and
that's it and we never will it ever
change I mean obviously as you get older
you're more accustomed to having
developed and thought back to write this
but I mean nonetheless Wilmont to be
open all the time the world changes as
well so you need to be able to take
account of things that change sorry that
seems to me to be so important because
this idea that you sort of sight write
this what I think I'm never gonna think
anything else I mean you might amuse
hide under the bed I mean what does that
mean I mean you should say you know how
boring would mean that you'd read a book
and nothing would occur I mean you know
then you'd never be able to watch a
podcast and your brain work because
you'd say no no no no this is what I
think I'm nothing else well you know so
for me it's because we all don't we want
to access new ideas to stimulate
ourselves to kind of test that and also
because by the way there's a lot of
problems in the world that needs solving
I don't need this many people kind of
addressing them as possible and you need
to be open minded to consider that I
think as well that the intellectual life
by the way is exciting and I think that
you know there's nothing more brilliant
than when you read a novel or you read
an I've just read under O'Hagan's
essay on Granville in the London Review
of Books it's it's like something like
30,000 it might even be longer think
thousand words masonries like a little
book
I mean yes I learn is the most perfect
essay and it makes you think it's
shocking it's moving reveals new
information it's a brilliant piece of
journalism
it's fantastically important way of
understanding the world and demos have
just brought out a new report on
nostalgia which is based on the notion
that probably people voted breath sets
and populism in France and generally
based on nostalgia a thesis which I
completely disagree with but the report
is well-written it's got great quotes in
it I loved it I kind of learned a huge
amount from it so I didn't grow the
thesis but one time and you know and
then I kind of bore everyone we judge
how good you've got read the demos bonus
oh you got me the Ella as I'm doing with
you because you know things I didn't
knows not feasible so I believe
everyone's like that and everyone should
be like that and ideas are important
because society cannot move on cannot
resolve any problems cannot solve the
problems of humanity if we're not
constantly intellectually open to each
other's developing ideas that people who
are bright in the most taking ideas from
2,000 years ago and thinking about how
they apply today people who were not as
bright as us but they've got an
absolutely sharp wit who see something
in a different way people whose
experiences are different which is why
you know identity politics is one of the
great tyrannies of our time but that's
not to say that you don't want to have
any knowledge of somebody's personal
experience through that that created by
their energy because that can give you a
great insight as well so of course the
frustration of this kind of stratified
static dead intellectual climate that we
live in I could speak on this I know you
don't don't speak to me I refuse to
listen
[Music]
we talk to people on the right we talk
to Peoria on the left and I think it's
that it's the fact that we talk about
free speech a lot yeah yeah I think
that's the number one well yeah that is
a problem and I think you know we talk
about the tone of the debate on on the
hard left is is some of these these
terms like fascists racists and stuff is
the they you know they seem to think
that they're like you know in Karate Kid
the crane kick you know yeah they seem
to think that that's always going to be
the conversation ender and once upon a
time possibly it was problem is is that
you keep rolling it out every single day
on Twitter you know every single day
online for people to pay in Leon it's
such serious words it's such an awful
thing to be like like a genuine my
biological racist it's just probably the
worst sort of view that you could hold
so once people see that applied to
people to patent the on then then the
word has already lost its power and
that's what I think that they've running
up against now and that's and in a way
and this is a problem for the left is
that you know some legitimate cool I
mean it is very much the boy who cried
wolf
ya know isn't it some legitimate
criticisms of people and now people are
able to sort of shrug them off because
they're now looking in in a litany of
things where people have you know again
it's this thing hyperbole people have
tried to get get an idea across the line
with with emotion and guilt trips rather
than with reason and with because every
time Francis calls Tommy Robinson far
right so we get a bunch of people going
off all right
it's just a you know a normal guy and
you go well I'm any piece not for
risings what right and I think the
reason people now think that way because
that label of racist it's been so
debased that really knows what a racist
is anymore yes I mean yeah I think it's
well like this one the problems is in
public life is remember people get
accused of being racist
no one ever owned it either you know no
there's not a proven of racism but but
people say that things are Peyton the
[ __ ] racist right it all been caught
saying stuff that's racist
you know Mel Gibson I mean those phone
calls if you've never I mean they're
just mind-blowing my if somebody just
come out and just said you know yeah I'm
yeah yeah you know they never say this
arm and not only that they always go to
the opposite side I'm the least racist
person
you a little links you know me you don't
use those words mail if you're not a
little bit you know I'm just saying it's
a spectrum and you know you're closer
and then you are that in so I think on
both sides it's been fudged right you
get the people that according people
with racist and possibly aren't racist
and then people a clearly racist like
you say going no not me maybe you asked
anyone in the tiny community of my wife
right and and they'll tell you I'm a
lovely bloke we know a person that
possibly depends on me being in work
weirdly they will support you know my
character and one of the really
unfortunate things that were going on
particularly in the US was the the
debate about freedom of speech just
became a left-right culture war and if
you were in favor of freedom of speech
is because you want it to basically
shout obscenities among minorities
Mystica and that the left were entirely
just these kind of snowflakes who had no
idea what free speech was it's not
really like that so we got together this
series of speakers who we felt really
excelled at kind of putting the kind of
liberal to libertarians even progressive
case for freedom of speech so along with
our own Brendan O'Neill who spoke at a
couple of events Steven Pinker from
Harvard spoke guy called Camille Foster
spoken our identity politics panel Mark
Miller a few others and so the whole aim
of it really was to try and be upfront
in sort tackling this problem of
censorship of protests against because
people dislike identity politics etc but
to do it in such a way that drew out
what we think is some of the more
important arguments for it which I think
classically liberal and even progressive
which that particular time seemed to be
almost entirely absent from the debate
that way I mean why is it do you think
that the right wing you know the money
you talk about freedom of speech
everybody goes well you know that's just
you know that's just right-wing people
when you know and people a lot of people
would say that there's no problem with
freedom of speech particularly in this
country when you compare it with I don't
know Venezuela China or whatever else
why do you think people associate
freedom of speech with the right wing I
think the first thing is to say that it
feels like broadly speaking the kind of
censorship on a kind of state level as
well as the censorship you see on a
university campus just because the way
things are at the moment
tends to be people I've on a campus
could just be anyone who's kind of you
know to the to the right of Center
effectively finally observes being
censored because of the political
cultural motion university campuses and
I think broadly speaking I think people
think of censorship ultimately is
something which is reserved for
far-right nut cases and racists you know
and that is there's there's some truth
in that but nevertheless I think the
other aspect to it is there has been
this profound kind of confusion as to
first of all the fact that if you censor
anyone in any circumstance that there is
a point in which that will be used
against people you happen to agree with
and I think we're seeing that play out
in relation to some kind of old feminist
finding themselves on the receiving end
of censorship etc but the other thing I
think is the kind of this sort of
historical illiteracy of it really it
doesn't really take much for a political
culture to change and if you kind of
create the means through which what are
deemed to be extreme views can be
snuffed out either by the state or by by
campaigns or by university
administrations or whatever it won't be
long until those same tools are used
against you and I think what's kind of
interesting about kind of even
characters on the kind of us all right
or at least all light is they're
increasingly kind of getting people shut
down you know James Gunn this guy who
was directing the guardians of the
galaxy series effectively a bunch of
kind of like journalists dug up his old
tweets and got him sacked because this
dynamic say on social media where things
you might have said jokes you might have
made in the past that were offensive can
be used to effectively get you sacked
that cudgel can be swung by the other
side just as easily so I think it's it
tends to be it does I think it's a
combination of where the political
culture is at the moment but also
unfortunately just an incredible kind of
shortsightedness on behalf of a lot of
left-wing as these days that's why I
would say on that issue is like once you
invent this weapon hmm of destroying
people's lives and livelihoods because
they made some joke or whatever you
don't get to control who uses and and I
think a lot of people on the left are
now finding it being used against them
and I don't agree with it being used in
either direction but I think once you
once you make it legitimate to discredit
somebody on the basis of a tweet they
they post it at 3 o'clock in the morning
or whatever that's that's that's then
becomes the norm mmm but that becomes
the way that war the culture was waged
no exactly I think we're really starting
to see that that's going on both sides
now you know if you
compare the Roseann situation in the US
where she obviously tweets it's kind of
pretty racist stuff effectively and then
instantly there's this very concerted
effort to get us act you saw the flip
side of that with the James gun thing
now we could argue who are those two
people we find more amiable who's we
might agree with more and I'm sure where
all of us would but nevertheless it's
quite clear that as soon as you create
this dynamic it will be exploited by the
other side and it what I think the most
irritating thing about all of this is
the fact that it's a lot often people
who claim to be very radical who claim
to be about kind of really challenging
the consensus etc who are very keen on
censorship which to me is insane if you
go about branding everyone you just like
an extremist and insisting they be shut
down then if you are someone who's
trying to further radical ideas that's
something which is an incredible threat
to yourself and I think what it actually
shows is that vast sections of the left
today even though they like to pose as
very radical I think the fact that
they're so comfortable with censorship
speaks the fact that deep down whether
they realize it or not they're not
actually saying very much there's
actually that challenging to the status
quo in to those in power more often than
not listening to be on the side of
people who want to bolster state power
to do things that and to crush people
they disagree so I think it's quite
revealing on that level and do you think
students have become more censorious
mmm it's a tricky one because I the last
thing I want to do is come to smear all
students this kind of you don't do any
work I think I think it's definitely the
kind of extremes of student politics are
becoming more extreme and they're
becoming more vocal and I think the one
thing that has really been the
difference is the fact that where there
was always other people in the room
could be student politics could be
people within a university
administration who would kind of stick
up for themselves who would say look
we've invited this speaker but you can't
just on the basis of a small group of
you who are protesting this shut this
down because there are people who want
to hear this perspective challenges
perspective etc you know university
administrations would previously you
know consider free speech to be a kind
of guiding value and would resist
attempts to kind of censor you know even
up until about 10 15 you
there would always be these arguments in
these battles but the extent to which
these small groups of campaigners could
succeed was always somewhat more limited
because there were at least enough
people willing to stick up for freedom
of speech I think the big problem is
that a lot of these student protesters
these kind of intense
identitarian people who are really thin
skinned they've been given the moral
authority in these situations people
even are really concerned about
disagreeing with them because they know
the abuse that could be held with them
etc so there's a there's an element I
think of kind of cowardice on behalf of
a lot of university administration say
and I think in relation to students more
broadly I think there's a very strong
conformist climate which makes them more
likely to either just keep their mouth
shut or just kind of leave them to it so
I think that whilst these people who
always kind of exist in I think the big
change now is unfortunately there's just
so little pushback against them and I
think that has allowed them to kind of
chalk up more wins insofar as censoring
people and but also for their ideas
become more and more strange and more
and more extreme because there's no one
really in the room to kind of temper and
challenge them so what you're saying
really is not the students who have
become lost and surahs it's that the
silent majority has been come in
creasing Lemoore silent I think's I mean
I do start seeing those things changing
I mean because a lot of the work that
we've been doing sitting in the UK has
been directly with students we've run
kind of tours of universities working
with students to set up debates before
we've worked with them on developing our
University Rankings which we've done in
the last four years which looks at free
speech policies etc and there is a
growing number of them of left-right and
neither who are increasingly appalled by
this and they kind of recognize that a
lot of this really holds them in
contempt in particular because if you go
around saying that we can't have this
beaker on campus because it will hurt
you it will it will effectively either
hurt you psychologically or you might be
stupid enough to be won over by people
were really reacting to that and a kind
of visceral way and I also think because
of the fact that the bar for censorship
on campus has been getting lower and
lower I mean up until about ten years
ago it was really only about kind of
far-right nut cases that this debate was
had out but you know as of a few years
ago the stories you're seeing in the
newspapers Birmingham University banning
sombreros and I think this is create the
kind of business it comes to
appropriation because it's cultural
programs let's play this
the suppression bingo yeah what are some
other examples of things that have
happened I'm trying to think so there's
there's a lot around fancy-dress which
is quite interesting also cultural
appropriation is a strange mix of
cultural appropriation cultural
insensitivity I guess so to tell people
that contrast up as gangsters telling
people wish that's offensive to
gangsters that's offensive to gangsters
definitely a minority began to say this
what's interesting about a lot of these
kind of calls to sensitive I mean I
don't know who they've got in mind when
they say that it's almost like in the
thing about when people are obsessed
with this cultural appropriation issue
is that they actually reaffirm
stereotypes kind of right they're
suggesting this will be you know
offensive to x-y was that group I think
it's the thing that really makes not so
much laugh but worry I guess it's the
fact that you've even had it seems like
so many kind of people in student unions
who actually do the lion's share of this
kind of censorship on campus they always
have so little self-awareness that you
have ridiculous situations like no
gangster costumes or things that we've
been saying seeing recently over the
last couple of years which is free
speech societies for instance being
blocks exist and I think my favorite
example was a couple of years ago at
University of Oxford where a bunch of
students got together in response to
become Soros climate on campus and
wanted to start a free speech magazine
called no offense yeah and it was banned
from the freshers fair please I think
that's just I think goes to shows the
fact that so much that we see on campus
it's so ridiculous
yeah it's often tempting I think whether
you're a student there or actually just
looking on to think why does it matter
but I think actually it speaks to how
unchecked a lot of this has gone because
we're not even talking about things that
anyone with a modicum of common sense
would think we're a problem anymore it's
really gotten that bad it feels like
there's always follow us on social media
at trigger pond
subscribe to this YouTube channel if you
enjoyed it and also as well um if you
really like it just recommend it to
someone that's it tell a friend and most
most importantly if you've already
subscribed click that bell right next to
subscribe button to make sure you get
notified every time we release a video
and thanks a lot for watching see you
next week see you next week bye bye